[موسيقى]
التجريشه تقليد شعبي شهير في مدينه حائل
شمال السعوديه وهي عاده اجتماعيه يحرص
الكثير من الاهالي على احيائها بدءا من
منتصف شهر شعبان وحتى قبيل شهر رمضان من
كل عام
[موسيقى]
مثل هذه الليالي يجتمعون يتبادلون المؤن
وكذلك يتبادلون الزاد ثم بعد ذلك تطورت
شيء فشيئا حتى وصلت الى انه كل الاعمى
تجتمعون حالهم الخوال اهل الحي
القريبات تجتمعون يعني ويحتفلون بها احدى
الليالي سعاده لقرب شهر رمضان المبارك
وكذلك توديع للاحبه والصفاء للذهن وصفاء
للود اللي بينهم وكذلك يعني اذا كان هناك
بعض الضغائن وبعض الشحناء اللي بين الناس
انه تروح
جرت العاده في مثل هذه المناسبه على اعداد
الاطعمه الشعبيه الحائليه التي اشتهرت بها
المنطقه كالمقشوش والثري الى جانب الهريس
والتمن والجريش فضلا عن طبق العاده الكبسه
النقطه الاساسيه ليست بتكلفه وانما
الاهتمام الدقيق في عمليه الطبخ انك
تعطيها نفس الحقيقي هذا الميزه ترى
الاطفال الصغار يلبسون مسرح يتزين يمحن
حقائق شوي
تعطيهن مثلا انت مثلا على ريال الريال اذا
شفت المراه البنت الصغيره مثلا زينه والله
والله جانا اربعه خمسه تجمع ليش تجمع من
الان خشره للعيد
[موسيقى]
هذه العاده القديمه كانت تقام حصرا لابناء
لعائله الواحده او في نطاق الحي عادت في
السنوات الاخيره لتشمل شرائح اكبر وعلى
نطاق اوسع بهدف الحفاظ على هذا التقليد
المتوارث منذ سنوات طويله
من مدينه حائل جزاع النصي العربيه